- Good morning, good morning everybody.
Thank you for attending this session.
My name's Russell Yates.
I'm one of the principal sales specialists
for Amazon Connect based in the UK.
And it's my pleasure today to talk about
how we can transform
customer contact centers
in financial services with Amazon Connect.
Today's gonna be about
split into three sections.
I'm gonna give a bit of an introduction
about the financial services industry.
And then I'm gonna be joined on stage
by Maggie Beddow, who is the
VP of operations for Zepz.
And Maggie's gonna explain the journey
that Zepz have been on
for the last few years.
But let's start with a thought.
You can't do today's job
with yesterday's methods
and be in business tomorrow.
And I think we could
probably all think about
organizations that we do business
with in our personal life
or even in the contact center industry
who just maintain the status quo.
They stay doing what they've always done.
And then competitors change
the way they did things
and they were either overtaken
or maybe some of these
businesses went out of business.
So it's really important, very Amazonian,
that we always try and think
about tomorrow, innovate,
and we're gonna be
talking about that today.
So let's talk about the
competitive battleground.
So what's changing?
Historically, organizations would compete
on all the basic things, price, service.
In the financial sector,
things like the rates.
But these are just commodity items now.
Everybody can pretty
much do the same rates.
Everybody can deliver the next day.
Everybody can do that.
So the new reality is
that customer experience
is the only sustainable advantage
that you can have
against your competitors.
And when you think of the businesses
that you deal with on a day-to-day basis,
I think of the businesses
that I deal with.
Of course, I'm gonna say this, Amazon.
Amazing customer experience,
deal with everything,
know who I am, and shape
the journeys based on that.
And really, that puts us in a position
where the customer experience
provides the competitive advantage
that we have in a very congested market.
The other thing to think of is,
so while your competitors are worrying
about the price or the rates,
people are expecting
digital-first experiences.
Historically, you had
tech-savvy millennials
who wanted everything like that.
But we've seen the reports now.
Across all demographics, ages,
everybody is looking for simple
and easy-to-use digital experiences.
And that's really where
the new battleground is.
Let's look at the fintech paradox.
So this is for, I'm talking about this
for financial services businesses,
but I know some of my other customers
and people from different
industries are in this room.
But I think all of these
are relevant as well
for any business in a market.
So scale versus quality.
So the more customers we have,
the more complexity we have to deal with.
For cost versus experience.
All of the management teams
are telling us to reduce cost,
but we've gotta give a better CSAT,
we've gotta get a better experience.
The innovation and the stability.
So let's deliver new things,
but don't break anything
that's already working
'cause we don't wanna upset our customers.
And then the global to personal.
We wanna speak to people
all over the world,
we want to do everything,
but we've gotta maintain that human touch.
So it's really difficult.
We've got all these
things pulling against us,
which makes it really difficult.
And what makes that even more difficult
is if you've got old legacy technology.
So let's look at the AI revolution.
But what we have today is
generally traditional systems.
We have got customers,
and hopefully we've got some
Amazon Connect customers
in this room, but I
know we will have people
who are using legacy on-premise systems
where in the IVR we
use rules-based routing
or routing for our US colleagues.
We've got long wait times.
So when you go into the system,
there's no personalization,
there's no prioritization.
So customers sit in long
queues waiting for agents.
And when the call gets to the agents,
these agents are probably burnt out
'cause they're using multiple systems,
they're trying to find information,
it's really difficult for them to do that.
So let's look at the AI-powered world now.
So what is in the AI-powered world?
Intelligent deflection.
Maybe that ability to
deflect the conversations
before they even reach a human agent.
Predictive routing or routing again.
The ability to make
decisions based on who I am
and create true personal journeys.
Think of that Amazon experience.
They know why I'm contacting them,
they know why I'm doing this,
and then routing it to the
most appropriate agent.
And then real-time insights.
We can't improve if each
and every interaction
that we deal with doesn't allow us
to improve on the last one.
So these are the things
that are in the AI world.
But here are the things
that are a bit challenging.
This is the promise.
Everybody's been promised,
we've heard about AI for years.
30 to 50% saving,
and I'm gonna increase
my customer satisfaction.
But we all know that's not the reality.
We know that people have
come and made these promises.
Consultants, vendors, industry experts,
we're just hearing about it,
but it's very difficult
to actually deliver.
And why is that difficult to deliver?
The reason why it's difficult to deliver
is most people are still
delivering AI projects
as like technology projects.
They're not thinking about the
end-to-end customer journey.
And that's really what you have to do
to make sure you're delivering
an exceptional experience,
because just dropping in a chatbot,
adding a bit of automation,
doesn't mean that the journey's
gonna be good end-to-end.
And that's why it makes
it really difficult.
We want our customers to
have a simple journey,
not feel like they're going through a maze
to get to the right person.
This is a sobering statistic as well.
It's all a bit doom and
gloom at the moment,
but it's gonna get better, don't worry.
70% of digital transformation
doesn't meet its goals.
And these are the common
features that we see.
Over-engineering, as I said,
just dropping in all
these different things,
different languages, different everything,
makes it really difficult
to have a seamless journey.
The next one being the vendor lock-in.
We may have agreed that we're dealing
with a particular bot
provider or a chat provider,
but without bringing that
into a single journey,
it's really difficult.
Then you've got the change
management resistance.
Most businesses have been operating
in the same way they've
always operated for years.
And this is probably
the most important thing
that I would ask everybody to think about.
You have to get top-down buy-in
for any significant change like this
for customer transformation.
Because if you don't,
there'll be people saying,
"We can't do this," or "We've
always done it like this."
And these are the things that
make that transformation.
Even though everybody's got
their best interest at heart,
it can be difficult to
overcome these changes.
But let's look at the success factors.
A clear vision.
So this is true Amazonian,
working backwards from our customers,
identifying what is gonna change
our overall customer experience,
and having a clear vision
and delivering against it.
Then having the right partnerships.
So of course we're gonna
say AWS and Amazon Connect,
but this is really important,
the ability to deliver on this vision
and having that across everything.
And then the final one
is a phased approach.
It's really difficult in
a business, as I said,
operating in multiple countries,
to deliver absolutely
everything all in one go.
So we talk about thinking
big, so we have that vision.
We start small, maybe
in a particular country
or particular channel,
and then we move fast and we accelerate.
And this is the way that we see
the most successful projects
run within our business.
But what does success actually look like?
Now I'm gonna be handing over to Maggie,
who's gonna talk about the journey
that Zepz have been on
using Amazon Connect,
and then we'll go back through
some of the new releases after that.
So Maggie.
- Thank you, Russell.
(audience applauds)
All right.
Hey everybody, my name is Maggie Beddow,
and I run operations at Zepz.
That includes a lot of things,
but fin crime operations,
payment operations,
customer care operations, of course,
and finance operations, to name a few.
And what is Zepz?
So Zepz is a fintech made up
of two mobile money brands,
Sendwave and WorldRemit,
and both of our brands have a mission
of empowering cross-border communities
through finance and technology.
So our apps primarily provide peer-to-peer
mobile money transfers at low cost
that are delivered quickly
and are easy to do.
So I was actually the first employee
at Sendwave over 11 years ago,
and in those early days,
if you guys can believe it,
I took all of our customer care calls
on my personal cell phone,
which got a little distracting
if I was at a grocery
store or in a restaurant,
but those were some of
the best times I've had
at this company because
I was able to connect
with our customers and learn firsthand
about the problems that they were
encountering with our apps.
So in those days, we were
making product iterations
pretty much daily, right,
based on these contacts
from our customers, and at that time,
we really had to treat every customer
like they were our only customer,
and that's how we were
able to get off the ground
in the East African communities
that we first launched in.
But then luckily, that
launch was successful,
and we began to see exponential growth.
That made it really challenging
to treat every customer
as though they were our only
customer, as you can imagine.
And so the remittance space at that time
was becoming increasingly competitive.
With the COVID time, we
had more digital players
coming into the market.
There's a race to the bottom with prices,
and so we were really
needing to figure out
how are we gonna differentiate
ourselves competitively,
right, and it became clear
to us that customer care
was going to be a strong
competitive differentiator for us
in the remittances space.
In 2021, Sendwave was acquired
by a UK competitor of ours
named WorldRemit, and then Zepz was born.
But as you guys can probably
guess with this merger,
a lot of complexity came,
and it became even harder
to deliver exceptional service
for all of our customers
across both of our brands.
So today, I wanna talk to you all
about how we face those challenges head on
in partnership with AWS.
But first, I wanna just give
you a little bit of a flavor
of why our business matters
with a quick intro video.
- [Narrator] Fair,
fast, flexible payments.
It's what we do and who we are, Zepz.
Powering two global
digital payments brands,
WorldRemit and Sendwave.
For over a decade, we've
been helping customers
save time and money when
sending payments across borders.
And in 2020, WorldRemit and Sendwave
jointly enabled 50 million
customer transactions,
sending $10 billion in payments.
Now, in 2021, we've become Zepz,
supporting fair, fast,
flexible digital payments.
Zepz brands, WorldRemit and Sendwave
offer market-leading
speed and accessibility
and it's our goal to provide
a world-class customer experience,
building innovative solutions
that offer choices to
solve customer problems.
By 2026, global remittances
could hit $930 billion
as they play an
increasingly important role
in the global economy.
Zepz is here to help make those payments
fair, fast, and flexible.
(upbeat music)
- Awesome.
So our industry has seen a lot of change
since Sendwave and WorldRemit launched
well over a decade ago.
Many of our original Sendwave users
were literally getting in their cars
and driving to physical pay-in locations
where they were going to send money home
to their family members
and often they would
have to pay large fees
even if they were sending
very small amounts home
and they wouldn't get a lot of
transparency into those fees.
Additionally, most of these transfers
could take several days to be delivered.
So before we merged and became Zepz,
both Sendwave and WorldRemit
were disrupting the status quo
and pioneering a digital-first approach.
Now those same customers that were driving
to the physical locations
can roll over in their bed
in the middle of the night
if there's an emergency and
send home money from their app
quickly, virtually instantly,
and then roll over and go back to bed.
So it's come a long way
since those early days.
Today, Zepz is a leader in the market.
We serve over 10 million
users across 130 countries.
We have built a robust payments network
with over 90 payment partners
and most of our transactions settle
within a couple of minutes, about 95%.
So we're well-positioned to capitalize
on the shift to digital
as the market for
international remittances
is projected to be a
whopping $2 trillion by 2030.
So this slide goes into
a little bit more detail
on the journey we've been on
to lower not only the transaction
fees for money transfers,
but also to bring more
transparency to these fees
so our customers know exactly
what they're going to have
to pay to send money home.
We've extended that
concept of transparency
to the status of our
customers' transactions.
Most of them get there very quickly,
but if they do not, we
have in-app trackers
that show our users exactly
where their money is
at any given moment in time.
And finally, we've tried
to make using our apps
simple and straightforward.
We believe that sending
money should be as easy
as sending a text message from your phone.
And all of this is because we know
that the about $16 billion we send
in transactions every year is mostly meant
for essential needs in
our recipient countries.
You guys can see some of
those needs listed here
like medical bills, school fees, rent,
groceries, utilities, child support.
Over 74% of our customers
are sending money home
for essential needs, and
that makes it very important
that we live up to our promises to them
of getting their money
where it needs to be
when it needs to be there.
And if it doesn't get there in time,
this is what our customer care agents
hear about constantly, right?
They are going to hear that the money
needs to be there urgently,
it didn't make it,
what happened, somebody's waiting outside
of a hospital to be admitted, right?
So it's a real challenge
for us to make sure
that we're able to give good answers
to those types of questions.
This is sort of an overview of many
of the operational
challenges that we face.
We operate in a complex landscape
with challenges, even
the emotional context
that I just described of somebody waiting
to get admitted to a hospital,
being very complicated for us,
and we need to be able to build trust
with our customer base that we are going
to be able to live up
to our promises to them.
So we also operate in a
highly regulated environment.
In the US alone, we are required
to have a money transmitter license
in literally every single state,
and all of the states
have different rules,
different policies, different procedures
that we need to keep up with.
It's a big job just to
maintain those licenses alone,
in addition to all of the other licenses
we have in some countries
across the globe.
We also have multi-language
needs from our customers,
they expect to be able to speak to us
in different languages with
a complex payment network
that I already spoke about.
We work not only with end payout partners
like banks and mobile money networks,
but also with many intermediary companies
that send to those payout methods.
So my teams need to be coordinating
across all of those partners constantly
to make sure there's no
disruption to services
if we're having an internal issue
or if one of our partners is
having an issue or migration.
And all of this is really in the context
of a very volatile FX
markets in some cases,
as well as volatile global
political environments.
So the broader remittance
market has provided challenges.
They're all listed here,
the digital acceleration that I spoke of
that really onset mostly
around the COVID times,
increased regulatory
scrutiny and pressure,
we're seeing it across
all of our regulators
in different countries.
They are bringing more scrutiny
to the mobile money space.
The cost pressure, right?
Because we are decreasing prices
and that's a really, really good thing.
It's our mission to decrease the cost
of sending money abroad.
But as we do that,
we need to think of other
ways to make money, right?
Because it's a race to
the bottom with pricing.
And then there's the AI revolution,
which is wonderful and
holds so much opportunity
for us to reinvent how we think
about operating our business.
So all of these challenges
paired with the complications
of integrating the operations
of two different brands
created the perfect
storm for us to weather.
A few years ago,
we had two entirely
different customer care teams
located in completely different places,
working with different CRM systems
and following very different policies,
procedures, cultural norms.
It was a big challenge
to start to think about
how we bring those two different teams
and all of their tooling together.
So enter AWS.
All of those challenges
were creating fertile ground
for us to bring in a new partner,
to really bring both of
our brands customer care
to a better place.
But it was a lot of work.
So we started with AWS in 2023.
And at that time, we migrated
all of our customer contacts
off of Zendesk and Salesforce
onto the AWS platform.
And then we were able
to kick it off in 2024
to start building novel solutions
for some of ZEP's needs.
That began with our email solution.
And then we brought AI into the mix
to help answer user inquiries.
And then we brought in what we call,
we did multi-language chat,
and then what we call
intelligent front door,
which is a mouthful,
but that essentially allowed
us to deflect customer queries
before they even got to an agent.
And we'd launched that
for both voice and chat,
and that was able to
save us a lot of time.
And you'll see in some upcoming slides
kind of how that affected
our contact rates as well.
Finally, we launched AI observability,
which basically allowed us
to see what users were asking
and how the model was responding.
So in 2025, we continued
to problem solve with AWS
to improve the quality and efficiency
of our call center operations.
One thing that was really cool
is that we enhanced our
multi-language support.
So most of our customer care agents
are based in the Philippines
and they speak English.
And what we were able to do with AWS
was to allow this team
to service our customers
speaking other languages via chat
by basically accepting
communications in other languages.
AWS translated them to English
so our agents could read what
the users were talking about,
and then they were able
to respond in English,
and that would be translated back
into the customer's native language.
That was really a step forward for us
because then we did not need to hire
expensive, hard-to-find language agents
as much as we previously
did in the Philippines.
So that one was really cool.
We also launched a few
other great time savers
One was case summaries.
So before we did the case
summary project with AWS,
our agents would be taking a call
and then manually typing in notes
about what happened on the call.
They would take a number of
minutes after each contact
to have to kind of relay what happened
so that if somebody came back to it,
they would be able to
understand what was going on.
AWS automated case summaries
for us, and that was amazing
because our agents now can move on
to taking more calls and more chats
instead of having to summarize the cases,
but we still have a great summary
so that the next agent who looks at a case
knows what's going on.
In a similar vein,
we also automated categorization of cases.
Another thing our team was doing manually
was to give a high-level category
to what type of contact
they were receiving,
if it was funds not received
or if it was an identity
verification issue.
This was time-consuming
for our agents, right,
because they had to look
through a whole list of things
and think about, "Uh, what
could this possibly be?"
So we automated that with AWS,
and that was a big
time-saver for us as well.
We also have, I guess,
really a cool AI-powered
solution to identity verification
that I wanna talk about quickly,
which we call ID and Verification,
and that basically allows us
to identity verify a customer through AI
before they even reach an agent,
so brings additional time
savings to our agents.
All right, so this is
the big numbers slide,
and you guys can see that
all of these projects
have had a profound impact
on our contact reduction.
So with this work, with AWS,
we saw a 51% decrease in voice contacts
between 2024 and 2025,
and with chat contacts, we
saw about a 33% decrease.
So if you think about that,
that's massive for us
operationally, right?
It's big cost savings for sure,
but it also allows our agents
to be able to get to our
customers more quickly
and more thoroughly to really work
on that market-differentiating
customer care
that we've been talking about.
So people often ask how we staffed
these projects internally,
and this slide just gives you a sense
of what our team looked like.
We have five people internally
that worked with AWS on these projects,
and I think a key thing
is that we really wanted
to have the AWS expertise in-house,
and so we made sure that
we had a lot of training
and that we built this internally
so that our team could
be making improvements
more quickly on their own
instead of having to hire an
intermediary to work with AWS.
And actually, one of these team members
is named Mark Russell,
who is a contact center architect at Zepz,
and we really wanted to
put in a quote from him
because I think he really
worked on all of these journeys
and I think has a perfect summary
of kind of the impact here.
So I'll read it aloud.
"Amazon Connect provides a rapid platform
"to quickly adapt to
customer and agent demands,
"enabling a fail-fast approach
"to deliver innovative
journeys across all channels,
"whether using AI or not,
"to deliver the best outcomes for all."
So that was really
poignant insight from Mark.
So on our end, we had many lessons learned
throughout all of these projects,
and we wanted to kind of try to lump them
into three big buckets
that hopefully will be
more widely applicable
for other projects.
So the first bucket is vision, right?
You need to be able to
know where you're going
before you figure out how to get there.
So lay out what success looks like,
what does good look like, and
then work backwards from there
as opposed to trying to
build a step-by-step roadmap
that eventually gets somewhere
but you don't really know where it is.
I think many of us probably
can relate to that, right?
Where we just start building
and we don't actually
know what our end goal is.
So that was something
that we really learned
through trial and error in this process.
The second one is velocity, right?
We wanna move with velocity
and be able to make decisions quickly,
especially if those decisions
can be reversed, right?
So we launch something,
we wanna see if it works with our users.
Okay, great, we can pull
it back if it doesn't work,
but we're gonna learn a lot
by putting it out there in the world.
And so let's do that
as quickly as possible
so we can learn as fast as possible.
And that's something that
we got better and better at
over time and we got less nervous
about just doing something
because we knew we could
roll back any changes
that were having an adverse
effect on the customer base.
And the final thing is automation,
which I suppose is an obvious one,
but really looking at what
are agents doing manually?
Like what is their day-to-day look like?
What things are they handling
that really could be automated?
And maybe we can't automate it today.
Maybe it's not the most important thing,
but let's have a plan to try
to automate it in the future.
Let's put it on the roadmap, right?
And that applies also to things
that our customers are doing, right?
If our customer is calling
in about something,
did they really have to
call in about this thing?
How could we enable more
self-service around it?
So those are the types of questions
that we're always trying to ask ourselves
day in and day out.
All right, so what's next?
As we sort of take these lessons in mind,
it's going to be essential
for us to keep them
in our operating procedures as we scale
and launch new product lines.
It's been a while since
either of our brands
launched a new product line.
We've mostly been bread and
butter remittance companies,
but we are launching a new
product on the Sendwave brand
called the Sendwave Wallet,
which extends our mission
of financial inclusion
to allow recipients to hold the equivalent
of US dollars in wallets,
and they can decide when they cash out
when there's a favorable FX rate,
and that really empowers them
with being able to hold a transfer in USD
until it's a good time for them
to get a good exchange rate and cash out.
So I wanted to give you guys
a preview of this product
because it's really exciting,
but it's, of course, also,
as with all these things,
going to bring more complexity
to how we service our customers.
- [Narrator] Zepz is transforming
from a remittance player
into a platform for financial empowerment,
and as we do, our customers
expand what's possible
in their financial lives.
The Sendwave Wallet breaks
the legacy remittance model.
The old divide with
senders in the global north
and recipients in the global
south no longer applies.
With the Sendwave Wallet, roles blur.
Any customer can now be a
sender, saver, and spender.
Money moves easily in every
direction our customers need.
Built directly into the Sendwave app,
customers can send, hold, and spend money
across 100-plus countries in seconds.
Funds are held safely in digital dollars
pegged to the US dollar,
designed to give customers
greater stability,
helping them support loved
ones and build for the future.
And the best part is, it's
already available today.
It all starts now.
Powered by trusted stablecoin technology
from Circle, Solana, and Portal,
the Sendwave Wallet is secure
and incredibly easy to use.
No hidden fees, no crypto jargon,
just seamless, real-world payments.
Imagine sending money to a loved one
and having them receive it in seconds,
ready to use for whatever they need.
That's the power of Sendwave.
With ZEPP's decade-long
global payout network
backing the Sendwave Wallet,
customers can easily withdraw funds
through trusted partners,
use their balance for real-world
payments and services,
going beyond traditional remittances.
It's more than just sending money.
It's about financial
empowerment, stability,
and dignity for Sendwave customers,
because every cross-border
payment is also an act of love,
a way to support families,
build opportunities,
and shape a better future.
- And so as we think about
kind of our next phase in 2026,
with the Sendwave Wallet coming into play
and, of course, our existing
remittance business,
what do we have planned?
And I wanna go over just a few things
before I hand it back to Russell.
The first is to improve our
automated customer surveys
so that we're able to
improve our AI content
on the back end of that.
The second is voice AI assistance
to offer 24/7 help, right?
Typically, we have to
have specific office hours
for our customer care staff,
because it's too complicated
to offer 24/7 service
with real humans.
And the last is live
voice-to-voice agent translation,
which you can think of
similarly to that chat feature
that I was talking about.
So this is the stuff
that's on deck in 2026,
and now I will hand it back to Russell.
(audience applauds)
- Thanks very much, Maggie.
I think one of the things
that's really empowering
of working with Zepz has
been their commitment
to use all the features and functions
that sit within Amazon Connect.
When I started working with Zepz,
and before the slide that Maggie
showed where it was email,
we were just looking after voice traffic.
Then Zepz started using chat and tasks
and contact lens and evaluations.
And a prime example was when
their current workforce
management platform
was coming up to renewal.
We did a demo for them on a Friday.
They looked at the solution.
They benefited from the free trial
that we offer within Connect.
And within a week, they'd
switched off their old
workforce management solution,
and they were using Amazon Connect,
forecasting, capacity
planning, and scheduling.
And that just demonstrated the commitment
of the team to always be innovating,
always using the latest technology,
and being able to deliver
that for themselves.
A lot of customers always ask me
about what's the size of the team,
and that's why we asked
Maggie to present that.
You don't have to have big teams.
That's really the nirvana
of where you want to get to,
where you've got a mixture
of either in-house teams
and partners to be able
to deliver the innovation
quickly and efficiently
for your customers.
Right, let's move on now.
We're gonna talk about
some of the innovation
that many of you will have heard of
through the last few days
with the announcements
from Amazon Connect,
and I'm gonna touch on a few of those now.
But I think it's worthwhile first starting
with the vision of where
Amazon Connect has come from.
And some of you may have been
at the Amazon Connect
networking event last night,
and we were talking to Pasquale de Mayo,
the vice president for Amazon Connect,
about the journey that we started on
and the challenge that he'd been given
by Andy Jassy to grow this business.
And as many of you will have
seen in his presentation
and Matt Garmin's presentation yesterday,
Amazon Connect now generates
a recurring revenue
of over a billion dollars a year.
So you can imagine from 2017,
we started as a disruptor in this industry
with very basic features
and functionalities,
today to being recognized
as one of the leaders
by all the key consultants.
And when you think about this,
if you look at this across
each of the top lines,
so the first one being the
communications channel,
when we started, we had
a basic voice solution,
and now we have an
omni-channel agent experience
that provides AI to allow you to have
agentic AI experiences
that I'm gonna come on
and talk to in a little bit.
In the agent empowerment line,
we started with a basic
customer control panel.
Now we have a multi-agent AI platform
that gives assistance to
agents during conversations.
And then on the bottom side,
we just had basic historic reporting.
Now we have AI-driven agent evaluation,
forecasting capacity planning,
the ability to do these
things in multiple languages.
This is so much game-changing
that allows you to stay up to date
with what your customers are demanding.
And in those times,
we're now launching over
200 announcements each year.
There were 29 that we made the other day
when we did all the announcements,
but you think 200, that's four a week.
This is the pace of
innovation that we're doing
to allow you to keep
up with your customers.
Let's move on to this
quite complicated slide.
You'll have seen these
sorts of slides before
with all the different things,
but I'm gonna explain this
in a little bit more detail.
So Amazon Connect creates intelligent,
adaptive customer experience
journeys in the agentic world.
And we think of these experiences
in four particular ways,
and this is the top line here.
So firstly, the understanding.
The understanding is about comprehending
what customers are asking us,
understanding their intent
across any particular channel.
We've then got the reasoning.
What's the next best
action that we need to do
based on the systems
that we have internally,
but also what the
customer may be asking us?
The next thing with the
agentic world is the action.
We've actually gotta deliver this.
So if the action is to make a refund,
update a system, change an
address, that's part of it.
And then the final one being the memory.
We need to capture this information
to deliver those journeys.
So the next time I contact,
we're taking that context into it as well.
So those are the four main components
that we see in the agentic world for CX.
We then move down to
the intelligence layer,
which are the foundational levels
that sit within Amazon Connect.
So we're gonna start on the
bottom left-hand side here,
which is the knowledge.
So things like customer profiles.
So customer profiles, the
internal enterprise tools,
and systems of record that
you have within your business
to make these decisions.
Amazon Connect now services
all of our customers
in any channel that you look for,
voice, chat, email, WhatsApp,
all of the things there.
That's the next layer.
The next layer up is
the orchestration layer,
which is the true agentic world,
which is where we're looking
at AI-generated workflows
where we're pulling information
from various sources
to make intelligent decisions.
And then the new announcements
about the AI agents,
we're moving on to the
right-hand side now,
which is the out-of-the-box agents
that sit within Amazon Connect,
the ability to create custom applications,
custom agents within Amazon Connect
for specific use cases that you have,
and then probably the most exciting
is the third-party agents,
allowing organizations like yourselves
to make the decision and
give you ultimate flexibility
to use what comes out the box,
what you can create, and third parties.
And now gone are the days
where you've gotta just stick to one.
This is allowing you the
freedom and flexibility
to choose whatever.
Using analytics, we've
talked about it already,
conversational analytics,
understanding what's
happening in real time,
sentiment analysis at
each and every stage,
agent performance, the evaluations,
and then forecasting capacity
planning and scheduling.
And then finally, the observability.
None of this is of any use
if we're not tracking this,
as I said at the start, this
true end-to-end journey.
How do we make sure that we're tracking it
for the end-to-end journey?
This is also about testing and
simulating these experiences
because in the agentic world,
we can try these things out
before we fully deploy them so we can see.
And then the final thing
being the analytics data lake,
that ability to capture data
and then look at those end-to-end journeys
and see are we delivering
what we're saying for our customers?
So this now gives people
the ultimate choice.
Amazon Connect is in the agentic world.
Agentic AI sits within Amazon Connect now,
and this gives you a choice
across all the channels
and all the ways that you'd
want to deal with your customer
to allow you to deliver those
exceptional experiences.
And as I said, Amazon Connect
is now in the agentic world,
and I'm gonna focus on
two that start here.
Action with AI, which
is how can we automate
as much as possible and allowing
humans to make decisions
when contact gets to them?
And then evaluating your
workflow, workforce, sorry,
elevate your workforce, which
is where when you're speaking,
when a contact does come to a human agent
after it's been with an AI teammate,
we give them as much information.
So let's look at these.
So we're gonna talk about agents that act,
natural voices, and AI evaluations.
So Amazon Connect is now agentic,
and what this means is it's the ability
to be able to pass basic information
from an AI agent into the workflows,
things like what number they called us on,
what webpage they're on,
information that's gonna help us
deliver a better experience.
We can then integrate with knowledge bases
and various tools and collaborate
with those third-party agents that I said.
And then finally, the things that are
out-of-the-box AI agents,
and if you go to the demo
booth in the Venetian,
you will see now how these
are built in the workflow
where we can pull the
out-of-the-box AI agents
to do simple tasks that
we've historically done
with physical agents.
Now this can be done in the agentic world.
Natural voices.
I mean, if you've been
working with Amazon Connect
like I have for nearly five years now,
the voice quality of interactions
when they're automated
has a real impact on our customers
if they don't wanna talk to robots.
And now, since April when
we launched Nova Sonic,
we've now grown this
to allow our customers
to have the access, if
they're using unlimited AI,
to things like 11 Labs and Deepgram,
which allows you to have better languages,
better understanding,
handle interruptions better,
all the things that you need
when you're trying to create
more natural experiences.
And then the final one in this section
is about AI agent evaluation and insight.
So today, many of you will
use our evaluation tools
to measure and monitor
existing interactions.
And this should be no
different than what we do
with AI-generated evaluation.
So you can do this.
It measures them in the same way
to make sure we're giving
a consistent approach
across everything.
And then allow human
supervisors to monitor that
and see what's happening.
So let's change gears now.
Let's go back to Elevate, your workforce.
We're looking at agentic AI assistance
and case summarization.
So with agentic AI assistance,
this allows our agents to be helped
almost in a way like step-by-step guides.
If you've used Amazon Connect,
step-by-step guides
was originally launched
for our customers, then for
our own internal agents.
And now this is being able to help agents.
So when they're in tricky conversations,
it can actually do the task for them.
It can help them customize
these actions and behaviors
and guide them through these experiences.
Again, moving away from this burnout,
we're there to help our agents
do each and everything
in every interaction.
And then finally, the case summarization.
This is using Amazon Connect
cases and taking information,
summarizing this across
multiple key stage insights
to enable agents to update the cases,
summarize them and have the
sort of streamlined approach
that they're not spending ages
writing up work after the call.
They can move on to the next one
and we know that that's trusted.
So let's go back to the start.
I said to you, thinking about,
can you do, you can't do today's job
with yesterday's methods
and be in business tomorrow.
And what you heard from Zepz
and what I've talked about
with all the new releases,
hopefully gives you food for thought,
gives you the encouragement
to go and try these things
and encourage you to use Amazon Connect.
So there's a big program of
other talks still going on,
as I said, also at the Venetian,
the Village Booth A13 is where
we've got some live demos
so you can see all of
this stuff in action.
We've got three other sessions,
there are other sessions
at the MGM here as well.
So please join those.
And now we've got a few minutes left.
If anybody would like to ask
myself or Maggie a question
about anything we've discussed so far.
Thank you.